the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello and welcome to our broadcast of
the 2023 spring chess classic my name is
Julian perlaco and I'm joined by women's
Grandmaster tats of abrahamian as we
take a look at both hotly contested
tournaments hello everyone and thank you
for joining us we are nearing the end of
the tournament today is round seven and
we had a really bloody run yesterday so
let's see where that left us as far as
the standings go so in group a we have a
three-way tie between Dr Swiss
Christopher you and Benjamin Bach
Benjamin Bach who won two games in a row
the game from Toronto in round five with
that really beautiful Bishop versus not
end game and also yesterday
that's a very interesting queen versus
three minor pieces and we have a big tie
for fourth place with ili niznik
Benjamin gladura Daniel Darda and Yasser
quesada all of whom are half a point
behind chasing the leaders and in group
b
we had two decisive results and we see
Felix blauberger who won his game
yesterday in clear first with four and a
half points he grinded down that came
against akshar Chandra with opposite
colored Bishops and Rooks and queens was
a bit of a complicated position and he
got the best of akshat and now he's in
the lead and Jason Liang who also won
his game yesterday is half a point
behind in second place in third place we
have a tie between Victor mikolevsky and
akshat Chandra a Victor won his game
yesterday he has actually five decisive
results in this tournament he's a very
combative player and akshat
unfortunately who lost this game is at
three enough points and we have a tie
for fifth place between gergelicantor
bambasuring vatsuran and Luca Buddhist
sablevich
so let's take a look at the format these
players are playing game in 90 minutes
with 30 second increments starting uh uh
starting from move one and will last
throughout the entire game at move 40
They will receive an extra 30 minutes
for the rest of the game with of course
a 30 second increment
so the remaining rounds will be tomorrow
at 1pm and on Thursday they will
actually begin uh two hours earlier at
11 A.M Central Standard time we will be
with you every single day two uh two
hours after the start of each round
and let's take a look at what we had
ahead and let's take a look at the
pairings so we have two of the leaders
in group a playing each other Benjamin
buck and Christopher you and actually as
we're starting this broadcast this game
has ended and our next key matchup of
the day will be between taro and
um Abi Abi is not having a very good
tournament so far but of course he's a
very strong player and very well
prepared player so let's take a quick
look at the game between Benjamin Bach
and Christopher you and let's see how
this game ended and we see this game
ended in a rogue end game with two
versus two
we can't quickly take a look at how we
landed here
so we have a Catalan with Bishop B4 no
it's three it's not the world
championship
so Bishop B4 check and we have sent this
line already several times here
so and queen C2
so trades in the center
so all of this so far is Theory so I see
some top games for attachment versus
Carl sending Loren versus Anish giri so
this is what we call hanging ponds and
usually this kind of ponds so it's very
common when we have an isolated Pawn to
transpose into hanging ponds whenever
the trade happens on C6 so long term
hanging plans are a weakness because
there are no pile no pawns on the
adjacent files to defend them so that's
why they call hanging so they can become
a long-term Target but the compensation
for hanging pawns is the same as for an
isolated Pawn piece activity
and in this position
targeting this Rook V8 indirectly
attacking This Bitter Pawn with the idea
being takes takes and takes on B2
silver trade on before
now this Pawn is under attack and B3
right so I'd say one advantage over the
hanging Pawn with hanging pawns over the
isolated Pawn is it's much more
difficult to win the win the backward
Pawn on C6 so it's easier to defend with
something like Bishop to D7 just it's
it's harder to get your pieces to attack
that square on the other hand uh you
don't have the C file and as you
normally would with an isolated Pawn to
put your Rooks and made the Queen's a
queen on
so another thing I noticed is this
Knight is not developed yet this Knight
would like to be on D4 or C5 and a bit
of a downside that this backwards um
well this Pawn can move in the future
but there's a light Square Bishop
and so but at the same time this bishop
is being locked by this Pawn so there is
nothing on the
um this diagonal is blocked so Bishop E6
is played giving up this Pawn but uh
this runs into a tactical problem
because C1 is hanging so actually this
gives black an opportunity to develop
the bishop on a better Square on E6
rather than D7
as a tactically just works out so white
has to develop this Knight Knight goes
to C3 which gives black the chance to
play C5
yes C5 is a quite a committal decision
but probably now is the right time to
play C5 when white has blocked the C
file when you have the pawn on C6
obviously it's harder to attack the D5
Pawn but when you play C5 you gain some
space so the D4 square is no longer
available to White and also um it's
harder to play something like Knight A4
C5 because Knight A4 might run into a
move like C4 with black
so if I was fighting a 9
A Night Like This C4 immediately or rook
fc8 and followed by C4 I don't think it
will be possible to take this Pawn this
looks
all of these are options
so Knight equals to E2
so Rook fc8 so of course not this rock
this Rook uh is actually doing something
on the B file because at some point in
their C4 or A4 will come so this B file
will open
so Rook fc8 Knight F4 C4
yeah it's interesting to note that black
play C4 once the Knight can no longer go
to the D4 Square so black times this
such that White's response is not Knight
to D4 because that would be a good
Square for the Knight yeah now
tactically there is no time to reroute
tonight so takes on C4
a lot of Trades are happening Bishop to
G4 and we see that black got rid of all
his weaknesses so black has already
um
is in no danger anymore because there is
no hanging pants and there is no
isolated phone right why would black be
worse is the exact same structure if
anything maybe Black's pieces are a
little bit more active than whites but
maybe not also White's pieces are pretty
good so I think we're going to see more
trades
so he doesn't want to take this because
this
[Music]
this maybe you didn't want to deal with
this so it goes Rook um C5
captures happen luckily there is no
background mate and found to A4 with the
idea of playing Rook to B2 and of course
moving the pawn from the attack still no
Checkmate yeah and black was not foolish
enough to fall for Bishop D5 Rook C8
which would be an unpleasant way to lose
the game yes
so all of this trades happen
and we'll see how the game ended so both
pings are cut off
puns get traded and as we reach move 40
as the rules dictate not draw before
move 40 what once where 40 the players
agreed to draw seems like a fair result
a pretty balanced game and the next game
is taro versus a game which becomes a
pretty important game right because the
two leaders Drew each other so if daro
wins this game then he will manage to um
uh catapult himself into clear first not
just a joint first
so what is your first impression of this
game as we did see daru at the poor
thinking while his opponent was away and
Dara has actually ahead on the clock for
almost 40 minutes to 16 minutes on move
33. yeah unfortunately for Doro I
actually like Black's position better
here because I like the K97 and the two
Central pawns I think the e-pawn is a
little isolated I don't think that white
should be like losing or anything but I
would much prefer to play Black's
position here yeah I also prefer Black's
position uh the bishop is just a better
piece and the pawn structure favors
black there's a clear weakness and this
looks like a sicilian end game and
usually Sicilian endgame's favor block
because of the structures and let's see
how we got here so E4 C5 so we got here
from I'm assuming would be Knight of
Mishra is a knight of player so Bishop
B5 we said this Christopher U game
Queen F3 and in that game after H6 Queen
H3 was played but here thorough plays
Bishop F6 which is the main line and H4
an ap6 this is some like very modern
Theory I suppose I don't I'm not super
familiar with uh with night or Theory oh
yeah I've never played this bishop G5
lines I prefer playing the English
attack
with F3 Bishop E3
so it's pure pure aggression
yeah so this is all is uh so far so Rook
D2 is the more common move here so I see
some games that have been played
server goes to D3
and uh this uh tension is interesting
because
a black doesn't really want to touch
this for a while white is also not
certain if they want to capture and it
is clear that the black king is going to
go to Queen side there is no way for
black to ever Castle this side and it
then becomes a question of whether or
not the king will be safe on this side
because the Rook is ready to go on the C
file and the structure is such that it's
possible that the king will get attacked
there too yeah I totally agree with you
I think the reason why you don't ever
want a castle inside here is like in
opposite side Castle's positions
obviously the side that can attack first
is the one who um is probably going to
win the game and white is just so far
ahead here and plus there's lots of
structural damage black is probably just
dead
so let's go to the game and in the game
he took on H6 which I think is a bit of
a communal move because there's still
useful moves white can make like King B1
whenever we Castle queenside uh King B1
is a useful move to defend this A2 pawn
and usually they say queen set Castle is
a tomb of uh Castle because they have to
play King to B1 so I don't so as a St
Louis player uh Ben feingold's role was
always if you Castle Queen side always
play King B1 yeah it's well familiar
like 99 of the time I think it's a
useful move but I'm wondering if he
didn't like hghg because that's
take it because
the downside of taking immediately white
gives himself this weakness and I
thought maybe he would follow up with
something like but Queen G3 runs into
Rook G6 so that's also it's not a big
deal but I'm not sure why
I give ourselves this weakness maybe the
idea is to play H5 Rook G1 was Queen G3
Rook G6 so clear though because after
Rook G6 Queen H2 I think white might be
threatening something like H5 or F5
dislodging the rook and trying to go
after black skin immediately
so if I do something like this yeah well
against Queen side castles I was
thinking more H5
because you've got your cane out of the
center and then yeah maybe I can Target
the G7 Pawn
not immediately maybe you can no
immediately you can because this guy
hangs unfortunately yeah we need like to
do this in a smart way
because if we go Queen G3 I think I will
take or even play G6 well okay so I'm
also I'm noticing that maybe I had like
a trick
um so after you coincide Castle I can
move my knight somewhere I don't know if
Knight like Knight D5 right away
probably doesn't work because you can
play uh Ed Rook C3 then Knight C4 which
is unfortunate
um and yeah I guess you just cover with
B5 here because B3 Queen A3 I yeah I
actually get checked made it immediately
but maybe I can move my knight away to a
more normal square like
two or D1 D1 to E3 okay
okay I don't know so side step
um
can I try Knight E3 here
I just try and take my H4 Pawn okay
fun at all yeah uh F5 Maybe
I'm not sure you want to do this
I think you're creating too many too
many weaknesses yeah luckily for me this
Rook um
okay let's go back maybe in this night
so maybe here
so here here Queen
which I like because I'm buying this one
so Castle
it's not a clever way of doing things
maybe just Bishop E2 Rook D1
so Bishop E2 no this is a threat yet but
now actually we're threatening
so let's say you pass
this right
or no
oh you wanted Rook D1 yeah I just wanted
to go after the D Point ah so maybe then
I don't even need to rush maybe I can go
Rook D1 so maybe
so let's excuse me
I really like the bishop only two
because whenever I go H5 the bishop will
defend this Square this Pawn uh now I
can go it well
H5 and then Queen G3 because G6 I think
runs into Queen G5 and if you have you
must take because your Rooks are
attacked in a bad way and then age six I
think white has a positional Advantage
here yeah this looks really nasty
because I think I'm on time to do this
yeah because of this one tempo if I had
time to go F6 I'd be okay but let's say
you defend this and I go Rook F1
and immediately targeting and not
allowing you to break through maybe Rook
F3 is better so I don't allow the Knight
to join the game
it seems very pleasant for white here in
my opinion
yeah so maybe there was some trick with
this queen G3 but he played A3 which is
I would think why not to say three
immediately
or he probably didn't like this trade so
this is and like Castle
and then just keep the tension on the H
file and
basically say if you take on AJ they
take back and otherwise I just keep this
tension forever and maybe make some
useful moves like King B8 Rook C8 Knight
C4 or Bishop C6 and if I need to at some
point take on H1 so
right there's no way for white to force
a trade on the H file in his favor
so that makes that makes a lot of sense
so I think he did this so he's playing
fast so this is preparation by him okay
let me see
so I think he just likes this imbalance
so A3 Queen G4 going after the pawn now
Queen Divan with a temple
Queen F2
so he doesn't want to play here because
um so beef P4 is ambitious but it might
it might just went material
yeah after before the queen doesn't have
a so if I go here this must be yes Queen
right no I was thinking Rook D6 was okay
[Music]
you need to stay in the third rank no
but am I not winning your Rook on F7 oh
like
oh I'm hanging everything so my line was
a queen D6 then Queen C3 uh Queen f8
then if you go Kane C7 and queen F7
and then I take on G6 but unfortunately
for me I think
I think I'm the one that painting
material at the end you're getting made
it correct yeah
for me at latest defends it so I think
this is just meat
yeah that's unfortunate nice resource
for black okay so A3 this was the idea
so okay so this was all his idea to do
this is trying to
uh trap the queen
so Queen demand played immediately and
uh block responds with Queen F2 so
Bishop C6 okay actually Bishop C6 is a
move that traps Our Queen because we
take away the square and uh the claim is
there is no good way to defend because
this will run into maybe some
maybe not yet but can be annoying
so inside Queen 112 after that four Pawn
which is very logical
so repeat the position of course black
is quite happy with this repetition
and then takes on D6 and I don't like
this Pawn trade for white because you're
trading this weekend this expand for an
F4 pawn and now we see how we got stuck
with this Pawn right I think once you
trade the F4 Pawn for D like this is
very favorable in the night orphan
General because if you can put a piece
on E5 it can't really be dislodged by by
anything so I've seen positions where
the Knight is very strong in E5 and even
the queen could be on E5 and then
neither women sometimes see when there's
a block Pawn on A6 rack they go G5 they
sacrifice a Pawn Yeah like this just to
get the C5 Square now block got it for
free
um who who did that a lot there was an
American Grandmaster
um I want to say Casper
oh it was a Walter Brown right Walter
Brown was playing that way a lot I
believe
I'm real familiar so H5
eight six
I wonder if white is already doing a bit
of damage control here
okay now we see the Knight is going
there so so what immediately trades off
the Knight on E5 because if the Knight
were left on E5 by itself I think black
has a very nice position also if white
takes this this is quite a nice exchange
for black because you make a move
the Knight goes back and this Knight
against this bishop is very strong yeah
every day we say how strong Bishops are
and how you know bad Knights are but I
think this is one of those cases where
the Knight on E5 is yeah just dominating
the bishop the bishop doesn't have very
many squares that actually matter
so Knight F3 stream porcing a tree
and forcing all the trades so we're on
move 35 the question is is F5 is a huge
threat taking advantage of this pin or
can I simply play
King here and centralize my king but I
also think this king goes to the center
but the downside of this is now I'm
attacking this Pawn maybe you can play
F7 and then move this rook and at some
point try to get a five get a pass pawn
and play for activity there right I
think this end game even if objectively
is equal is very practically hard to
play for white I think black is
pressing here which is bad news for
Darrow
he obviously would like to to win this
game with white and uh be in the sole
lead but um I don't think it quite
worked out for him that way
um yeah I mean I don't think it's uh as
bad as we're making it so the fight does
a lot of pieces have come off a lot of
Pawns have come off which is uh always
helpful for the defensive side and even
in that position where we went with
centralized King which is very logical
right and now maybe something like Rook
H3 trying to check you and then before
C4 B5 if I manage to make all this moves
I'd be quite happy and let's say okay
let's pass the move you don't allow
check I go here you go here and then uh
maybe I can reroute my rook and go C4
and just try to trade a lot of Pawns so
I think
closer to I'm okay like I of course I
prefer black hero too but I think closer
to
equality than black having real chances
fair enough uh I think that would be my
assessment especially at this level
because it's just so hard to win games
at this level yeah
um so while Dara was thinking about this
uh why don't we go ahead and take a look
at the B parents
yeah and in section B we had assault
leader Felix blauberger and he is
um he's playing Victor micholeski today
and this is our key matchup of the day
and we see michalevsky he drew his first
game and he's very consistent he wins
with one he drew with black and then he
wins with white and loses with black so
so we see one zero one zero one and
today remains to a question mark and
Felix did win two games in a row so he's
on a hot streak so let's jump to this
game and see how it is going right now
and oh we see actually we were analyzing
it before so let's look at the live
position that we have and we see some
kind of a crazy imbalance to Rooks two
Bishops all aiming get the king but
unfortunate um unfortunately it's white
to move so black doesn't have time to
to deliver one of the many threats
yeah it's a it's a queen and pawn for
rook and Bishop which is obviously a
huge material
um a deficit for black but
um the Rooks on the second rank are are
scary to deal with so white needs to
find something concrete here
um or p is at risk of not winning this
game
so what are the threats so one Checkmate
two Checkmate Rook B2 and Bishop G6 I
think are all pretty massive threats so
um so in this position
I have to take on F7
header move makes sense
well we we could also check on the back
rank right I don't know if that helps us
or hurts us but I think we can do it
then like Queen C7 oh you go there to
stop I don't know where I go
so let's see here you check
um so I I cannot go on adventures or can
I go on adventures no you still have
checks I don't think this will work
so I think I will have to go
back yeah yeah you can't go to fa
because Queen d8 would be check
checkmate I believe but
[Music]
yeah but if King E8 also does not feel
good
right here can I take on F7 and if you
recapture I take on C6 and take on G2 oh
yeah yeah so here I was thinking can get
fade because I have so many threads I
don't think you have time to
um
yeah now we even have a queen for a rook
pure and it still isn't easy based off
of Black's activity
I wanted to take because if you take
with the Rook
and maybe yeah this seems like like
white should white should win um yeah
for I remember there was some like
semi-slave game between car buff and
Anand with a very similar material
imbalance the carpath
ended up winning
with the queen versus bishop and Rook no
no it was Queen it was like this exact
end game but like mirrored so white had
the pawns on the other side of the board
but it was Queen and two pawns
um a queen in three pawns versus rook
and one Pawn
so what if we play here we checked right
uh so maybe I went can I go here
stop in Queen C7 yeah so you check
[Music]
oh and I just don't have time anymore so
queen bee it would be a massive mistake
you just shuffle your cane from D7 to d8
and there's no more progress to be made
is this also yeah there's also sounds uh
run so Bishop F7 then has to be the only
move right by process of elimination
so it's
if you see he's thinking let's see how
much time he has spent he has spent six
minutes already so this is a critical
moment because here he has actually has
to find something because
um there are too many threats in the
position that cannot be ignored yeah
luckily after you if you take on F7
which I don't think you should do but if
you
um if you play Rook F7 and I think Queen
A8 is a better version because after
King D7 we have Queen B7 and unlike in
previous positions where you could
afford to play King d8 you cannot do
that because the rectangian on F7 and
next we will take on C6 or give some
sort of check that
wins the game yeah but that's where we
saw that checks can be actually hurtful
for us right I like how we're always on
the winning side when it's the one side
is winning we're like itself yes yes of
course no I never want to play a losing
position
so you have to well okay your queen is
hanging so you have to check I go I
cannot go on that file it's just silly
I'm blocking my Rook so I have to go
here uh Queen C7
oh it didn't change anything never mind
so you have to do this and I think how
did we get to that position that where
we took on D6 but I think because it
took on day six because we made a it was
this night so let me go back see how we
got here but we made a mistake right oh
yeah because we went King E7 but now we
realized just check is a mistake so he
has to take
so king f8
um I think this is also a possibility
right I wasn't sure what it was doing
against this to be honest with you
so I have to check you
at some point this has to be taken the
one is the king can't take so maybe I
need to be
okay kind of like a blundering so I have
to go to a square you cannot check so
this is how I know it's a blunder so I
have to go here but we saw this position
right we saw a version of this
yeah but maybe here Black's cane is just
running uh in the other position The
Rook was on F7 right so we like hear
Queen C8 King E5 and I think that
Black's cane will just end up running to
D4 into safety
all the squares are somehow like
controlled and like Keen C5 or yeah I
can't see
oh man I just I don't know why
why is that losing
um because okay let's check check I
think you cannot find the a file and if
you go here I have this I still don't
see the mate but this is mate you know
it's getting really scary okay
if I if I saw this far I wouldn't have
gone for this line obviously wait but
there has to be something easy
a week There's Queen Beast it's made in
two or well some small number Queen B6
and if can A4 then C5 and if King C3
Queen B
three
oh you have to go to D2
and then Queen C2 Queen uh Queen C2 King
E3 Queen
E4
no Rook
so
oh okay there we go
I had one game where my opponents can
run all the way to g2i checkmate with
him actually I was very happy he allowed
me to do it it was satisfying nice
okay so we got here by force all of this
has to happen I actually don't even know
what the position is because I don't see
their okay that's
right so we made 10. so okay but
apparently King C5 is a mistake so which
is King D3 keep going
there's probably a check from H3
[Music]
uh
and now I go here
oh wow messed up mate well mikina's
conveniently stopping my work from going
to B2 that's that's unfortunate this is
a final
maybe not as entertaining to play yeah
I'm sure both players are really
stressed it's very easy for us well we
have if we make a mistake we can take it
back you're like oh no every move the
price is so high
thing is he takes on F7 because if he
checks he has to realize that King D7
and he cannot make products because it's
just too many threads and he can he
cannot do it so the key is you have to
take on G7 with a check at some point
right
we saw it in another line and then you
defend this B2 with checks and then you
push your A4 Pawn so the key is that
this Rook so this Rook is actually a
very funny piece because it's on the
seven rank so it looks very threatening
and very scary but at the same time it's
not really part of the game because
there's this thread Zone the first Rank
and also you cannot do anything for a
check so you need your unit everything
has to be done by force here we have we
don't have time for a quiet move here
yeah but at the same time he's thinking
and he's such a strong player obviously
that there there must be like another
candidate a candidate move besides
Bishop F7 like maybe Queen E3 or
something is what he's thinking about
but yeah even here you just lose
but uh I think we're about seven from
from what uh from process of elimination
right which is a way to find moves in
chess you just eliminate all the options
and you're like okay I have to play this
uh I think Bishop of someone is the only
one
it's fair if if you know that one move
is like you're definitely gonna make
that move do you still calculate or do
you just make that move and think about
it later like typically
um I have a very bad habit of just
calculating anyways I used to be even
worse like if I was in check and my king
had only one move instead of just making
this one move I would sit there and
calculate what's going to happen next
which is ridiculous of course that
you're a fun and thing and make your
move get your 30 seconds
and then decide but the problem is like
I think about it and then my opponent
makes a move that I was expecting and I
still think about it so it's just kind
of pointless if you know you have one
move just make it
like sometimes I have this inert uh talk
you know he did it if you just have one
move make it and then he played it's
like he can hear you I know that's not
good for him but I have sometimes I have
this inner manner like I'm calculating a
move and then at some point that's for
like 15-20 minutes and I'm like okay you
haven't looked at any other move you
know you're gonna play this move like
why are you still sitting here just make
your move if it's bad at least you have
time on the clock to just make it so
like I have this inner monologue and
then I convince myself to make a move
but this comes from being a bit of a
time travel addict which I think a lot
of people struggle with
yeah
some and I would say it's an experienced
thing but I think it's just a
personality thing there are some people
that move too fast like I'm definitely
one of those people that moves too fast
sometimes and there are other people
that that don't move fast enough it's
never somehow it's never right there's
no
yeah like formula Curry shook right he
just spends forever and you cannot say
he likes experience the guy has been
around forever and plays in every
possible candidate World Police
Championship or rapid Championship but
he still takes a lot of time linear too
like in the American Cup we saw him so
many times make a move with a second lap
left left on this clock yeah and nepo
has lost many games because he moved too
faster just these things just last
forever
yeah and you know I have to say
sometimes when you see someone make a
move with a second left the second seems
to last so long when you're playing
you're like wait how did you do that I
thought you were gonna fly with one
second yeah the worst is when you play
somebody and they make a move with a
second left mini moves in a row you're
like how can you how can you do that
like not not once did you flag
it gets frustrating incredible and here
he is choosing between King f8 and Rook
F7 uh actually let's see how we got here
because I just uh looked at the opening
and this is looking very familiar so
he's you know all his games he's played
this right so first round
uh he drew against Kirk and then he lost
the game in this line and then he's
playing it again so he's uh you know
very dedicated to this line he lost to
Luca I believe is that is that true
um somebody who played D3 no no he lost
to Cantor right oh yeah yeah it was the
c3d4 line right yeah he lost the cancer
in this line so D3 was repeated again
Kirk played the move d4 so I guess
people have sort of figured out that D3
is the way to punish this line not
putting the pawn on D4 on this is the
same game this is what happened in the
previous game
so I asked the question why was Knight
E4 not played and then he played some
other move in the previous game and this
time he played 94 so there you go
I guess it uh depends and we had some
line right where this Rook was somehow
yeah I think it was like H it was H4 and
then Bishop C3 takes Rook E4 Bishop E2
Rook H4 yeah and uh somehow the fact
that the dark scores are weak doesn't
really matter because we control all the
relevant all the relevant squares
inside a place 22 which is a sane move
six and castle and I would really prefer
this position with white because I think
White's moves are so easy this H4 H5
this attack is just too strong
um so the idea is at some point maybe to
take and take only four but this is too
weak
and C6 but now with this of course you
cannot take this way you cannot just
open the whole file you have to take
with f takes G6 and at least you have
the H7 Pawn at some point you can defend
upon whereas if you take this way then
you have to defend like the file is just
wide open so this is too scary so this
is again a sane move F4
you should pay to it so it's a good
things about Bishop if it's an open
diagonal it doesn't matter where the
bishop is it does the same task
on F5 Knight E4 which apparently it's a
mistake although I can see why it's a
mistake because now the bishop comes in
it's kind of funny that your own pieces
get in the way of your other pieces
right the spawn structure gets in the
way of this bishop and actually by
winning the pawn black is freeing
White's attacking peace the black should
not have done this not totally sure what
black should have done though so what
what would you do with black because I
would be so scared I have yeah I would
be terrified like my opponent played F5
and I'm about to get checkmated I I
totally understand taking the E4 Pawn at
least if I'm gonna suffer I'd rather be
up material there's something like Queen
F6 and now Knight E4 is a threat nope I
said it like 94 is a thread question
mark and no it's not but at least I'm
you know eyeing this Pawn
maybe maybe I can maybe rookie force a
threat or no so if I pass well let's say
you want to do this right and it's the
94 and Bishop F5 maybe yeah this looks
quite strong
because somehow The Rook 98 doesn't feel
like it's contributing but the Knight on
e4 feels like very nice for black
this thing yeah I like your mobile for
rookie for rookie 4 looks very strong
but maybe here I even want to take and
if you allow me something like this I
think I might actually take wow because
if you take okay if you take I think
you're gonna regret it and I think it's
once I put a bishop on G6 you don't have
an attack because I'm controlling this
bishop once again you don't have a
square you cannot move the Knight right
actually you don't have a square to move
tonight and P2 is hanging
so I think this one is okay okay
that makes that makes a lot of sense
yeah 94 I understand taking this point
you know you've put all your pieces to
take this Pawn but
so we see this problem maybe taking the
uh the way that this can be described as
taking the E4 Pawn is bad because it
allows white to put uh to trade H pawns
whereas in other positions we were
captured on G6 with a piece
so
um the fact that black doesn't have a
Pawn on H7 like kind of hurts him here
yeah you really wish you had a pawn
actually you wish you had this Pawn
button right assuming you know you had
made it
but now all these pieces look at this in
one move by just giving up a pawn every
single piece is an attack where else
again we see um
we see this problem so he went Bishop B5
I was thinking he would go Bishop F5 at
least
um try to maybe Queen this seven and
again bring the queen somehow into the
game
but it's hard to give up the pawn bike
when you know you just hold a pawn and
you're like okay unless I grab the pawn
for my suffering he went he should be
five but the idea is he is stopping this
because instead of taking back here
Bishop F4 nice nice and neurot so
sorry so King B1 sidestepping still
threatening this
and now Bishop B6 but now okay so now he
played he won the queen and now this is
where the suffering begins so Rook F2
and apparently Queen H6 was a mistake
yeah I I gotta tell you Queen H6 was my
first candidate movement I I don't think
I could stop myself from playing that
okay I'm starting mate
I'm very good at spotting this
so you want Rook F2 so I agree you have
to
block this so one move is Bishop G7 but
this can not in any way shape or form be
good right so you cannot go to E7 I take
the bishop you go back I just take
everything
so this cannot be a good move so
here
wow
I mean there's no other way right
there's no other ways of meat right I
mean I'm not gonna go this episode but
Rook F7 and if I take oh if I take G6
you take G6 and play Bishop F5 no oh no
it's check hold on then why is this
working Bishop G6
what do you do here
it's a bit of a mystery because Rook F6
it's Queen h8 which is tough Rook G7
it's also a queen h8
so I cannot
cannot to go to F2 now you go to F2 now
and giving away giving away the the G6
Pawn helps you okay I understand then I
mean the only way I can understand this
by just looking at what happened in the
game and by having this
the bar of telling me this is good
because what happened in the game after
Rook F2 sorry Rook F2
and queen C7 whereas in this ridiculous
line of allowing this you don't have
time to do this
because your Bishop hangs
I remember what a Nuance ah but this is
also made
like this is like a black to play and
survive problem and the answer is Rook
F7 and good luck coming up with that as
a person with blood running through your
veins instead of silicone
this is no way you're ever finding this
so he take I mean the way black is
playing is just so human you put your
Rooks on the second rank your Bishops
are aiming and I think here very
logically and very um
like human thinking is you think you
have good compensation because I have
Brooks on the second rank two Bishops
I'm not kidding made it yeah before
Bishop is covering it before I saw the
bar I actually didn't even know who was
better like I thought that black had
lots of activity and
um white skin is quite weak
I mean okay I I I knew that white
couldn't really be worse because you can
give your professional but I wasn't sure
if uh if it was just Perpetual or not
so he plays Rook H7 the rule comes in so
now we see he picks up a few Pawns
so the King has to go here the king
cannot go anywhere where it's touching
this bishop because then we take it with
a check and the whole point of for black
the only reason is surviving is because
uh well not this one
this mating threat so now we see grabs
another Pawn so this is going to be key
because in a lot of positions at the end
when we take on G7 the reason why it's
going to win is because of this past
Pawn so you know whenever you have this
kind of free moves to grab Parts
definitely do them you also get moves in
you get closer to move 40.
so Bishop G6 was played right
promote this this confuses me a bit so
Bishop G6 was played and this is
impossible because this guy hangs
he took and after something he actually
spent nine minutes it's a substantial
amount of time he took on F7
so we're debating between take on F7 and
King f8 and of course that's what he was
considering there's no other legal move
in the position that made sense
actually it's funny because if you just
go the other way I think the easiest way
for me so yes let's win a piece enough
of this nonsense just let me win with my
extra piece
so Bishop F7
and takes and recap 7 on the board so
this queen
uh so if I check from here I don't think
it matters where I check from actually
it probably does Queen V8 right so here
check what we're doing here we're going
to E6 right
yes all the moves have been played in
the game and black chose to move Keen to
D7 and it looks like
is there
137 and King is oh there's a there's a
huge difference you're not threatening
this wow
so this King D7 might might have been a
decisive mistake because with the keen
on E7 Rook B2 is certainly a threat
because F7 is defended but Rook B2 here
is unplayable due to Queen B2 and Rook
F7 and the Kanan Pawn ending at the end
might be like simply winning well by
might be I mean it's it's definitely
winning uh Queen B2 Bishop B2 Rook F7
keaney eight King B2 is probably the
simplest way to win the king's just not
inside the square of the a pawn and you
will lose the game
yeah very nice wow this is such a big
subtlety and when you know when you're
playing and when you're thinking
sometimes it's very hard to kind of see
the difference between you like it's the
same maybe he didn't want to go King
seven because Queen C7 troubled him and
maybe he didn't realize King E6 is good
so let's see if Felix is reaching for a
move
I think the seven is the position so
there's still a mated threat this is the
biggest threat in the position and A4
will stop this threat and Rook F2 here
which is a really annoying move
tactically runs into a skewer
yes or even Queen A7 which attacks both
which attacks all of your pieces attacks
The Rook on G7 uh via X-ray and looking
for a clan F2 oh he did play for NFL
Network so Felix was in clear first
before this round and now he's he's it's
looking like he's um
separating himself from the rest of the
pack
and yesterday he had a very long game
against akshat it was a very long grind
and today's game is very different from
that game this is a very straightforward
attack and um
it looks like things are really going
his way it's hard to find a move for
black here
maybe you have to go back in year seven
but in this position as you mentioned
that King and pawn end game is winning
so I might just keep pushing the pawn
because again
this is not possible
yeah if it was winning before it's it's
extra winning now oh sorry
[Music]
sorry
they were shorter and once I move my
Pawn
next move you make some kind of a move
and push my pawn and my Pawn is quitting
here
so this is actually A4 was a really nice
move by Felix
and michalevsky's turn he has six
minutes to make four moves but
unfortunately I think the position
doesn't really offer much anymore
so what else can he play he went King B6
so now he goes King E6
and uh can we keep pushing this Pawn
Yeah without these mating threads I
think the black's position becomes a lot
worse yeah yeah yeah so the keen on D7
was the bishop was pinned and now now it
isn't
so now you can do this and now you take
so the reason the difference between the
skin moves this one move you know it's
like one placement of the king changes
the position and that this will be a
draw I think
most moves here will be a draw probably
Rook F2 is what I would play
to try and
um
get well yeah something yeah like Rook
F1 back to go Rook A1
yeah maybe even King E5 is okay
I don't know Kenny if I've tried the way
I think many moves I think I would try
to trade pounds and just make a draw
after So Many Adventures I just feel
like it's over but luckily with the
polyne4 black isn't threatening the same
sorts of checkmates that he was uh in
the previous positions so we can maybe
even give our Rook on G7 eventually I
give some check take the C6 pawn and
again we'll achieve Queen and two versus
Rook of all Queen and three versus rook
in one two Rooks and one so if I block
what will you play here
tempted to take and my claim is after
you take take I'm threatening Rook G7
but um I don't know if I'm thrilled
about what I'm doing here
I know we're not going to I mean
concretely maybe we're just winning a
piece here oh I have to make a move
right always
I have to put my Rook somewhere where it
doesn't hang which is a huge problem
um
yeah so yeah I see so if you go Rook F2
then I go um
uh I go Rook G no but here you've
no actually you don't do anything yeah I
wanted to do that yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so after instead of Queen G4 it can
take on G7 right and then if Rook takes
G7 Queen B7
because there you go Queen before yeah
if first if I go on the seven ring you
take it but if you go to 68 and again
there's a mating thread and getting
annoying again right and if you go to F6
then I have Queen H4 which collects your
Rook on F2 so I just don't think there's
this and also Rook at a king F7 is Rook
G7
okay so once we getting to a position
where most moves oh maybe I can go here
here there has to be something right
that's queen queen D5 kf6 queen queen F
oh wait actually no all right if I go
here as the same Motif so I have to go
here but I was thinking queen of three
oh no we can't change some water right
you can start with this move oh that's
yeah that's nice takes and then Keen F6
Queen F3 nice but I go here no then
Queen B7 protects Queen and queen F3
better yeah
yeah this is a
system it's changing the order of the
moves
is what makes it work yeah if ABC
doesn't work you go like AC and then B
for sure yeah okay so where are we in
the position we are King E6 I keep Miss
clicking things and we're considering
Queenie but there's probably a lot of
moves here maybe Queen C8 is also a
possibility
uh maybe it's I don't think bringing the
move back so Rook V2 is a threat so he
has to play a check
but I think this is uh quite clean and
here he must have many moves I don't
think Queen C6 is the only one maybe
Queen C8 is
something already
um the thing is like if I take on G7 and
then take on C6 for example if I check
you you go somewhere and I take like
this has to be winning right
yeah what I was thinking before you're
very clean Queen C6 move was
um you would play or sorry uh would
would play the move Rook D7 with white
and then I would just take take on G7 or
G7 and queen C6 and get a very similar
end game out here yeah like Rook G7
because you can't take with the other
rook and then Queen C6
thought the sun game was pretty nice for
white this will be very hard to stop
this pawn and
I mean maybe still some fight left I'm
still two Rooks but at some point I will
bring my king play before A5 and this
would be a win might take a few moves
but
I see mikhalevsky's thinking I think
it's reflecting back on the game trying
to figure out what happened what went
wrong
and so I think this should be
headed towards the wind for Felix of
course every time we say this something
bad happens
but he has quite a bit of time he has
eight minutes left so he's already spent
around five minutes thinking about this
and maybe he's already calculating
um till the end maybe he's just
considering group G7
but we expect him to be able to convert
this
yeah for sure so while Felix is thinking
about this position do you want to check
out some other games yeah
yeah uh actually I learned today that
Jack Jason won the Grand Prix U.S Grand
Prix 2022 you know when you play all
these tournaments in the US they all
have like Grand Prix points and then it
looks like the usual Grand Prix in the
world and then you collect enough and
you win it and I think you win a prize
wow so you actually won it so he's been
really grinding because you have to play
in all this open tournaments and the
position we have H5 is played I expect
this is headed towards a draw yeah it
makes sense that he's played in a lot of
tournaments because
um I believe I played in an event with
him last year and I saw his rating was
like 23.70 and now it's 25 30 which is
quite a jump and it's so hard to gain
rating in open tournaments because
you're playing so many underrated kids
and it's just such a grind with Toronto
day so I think this is such a huge
achievement to gain so many Grand Prix
points
so I'm expecting this will happen this
Pawn will be taken and the game will be
will end in a draw of course black
cannot do this
as
um we both Queen but when when I queen
his Checkmate unfortunately it's not
with a check
as will be made
but the position we have on the board H5
H5 looks like it's
trying to get rid of everything I don't
think King G5
maybe white can try here can I try here
actually
if I take
so you're your your ideas to play King
H6 using my Pawn as like a shield
well I have an F Pawn which I think is
more annoying than your pawns so if
let's say something like this I mean I'm
using the fact that I have two pass fans
I get H Pawn I'm attacking it I'm close
to it and your king is passive I have an
active King so he did go King G5 so he
is trying to play for a win actually and
the thing is the evaluation tells us
it's equal but a practical aspect is
very different and also actually did
lose a game yesterday a long grind so he
may not be in the best mindset so you
know you're just putting pressure on
your opponent and the Practical aspect
of it and just you know letting your
opponent giving your opponent the chance
to make a mistake yeah of of course a
computer will be able to hold this with
black but if you um agree to a draw as
white in all of these sorts of positions
then uh you're just leaving points on
the table
um black is not going to hold us 100 of
the time and that is why white is trying
to play 401.
like every time Magnus wins his endgames
is because he has an advantage
right he just yeah plays his positions
tries to create chances gives his
opponent
a chance to make a mistake they make one
maybe they become slightly worse they
have to play precise and then they make
another one
then keeps getting worse and worse and
then you win the game so something like
this so let's see how we can
um
we can
play for a dress so I don't okay so if I
go H4
so you push
I go for this phone so this one actually
starting to become a bit dangerous
so my idea was to do something like this
so for example if you take
[Music]
um
apparently oh yeah this is
maybe maybe
FS okay
F6 I think 9.60
C4 then I go King G6 and I think you're
in big trouble I think I'm just made it
right yeah F7 next
so here yeah F7 700 yeah very
unfortunate yeah so here already well
taking a pawn is a mistake
so then means you can I push
I'm threatening H2 right so you cannot
really get adventurous because I check I
push
yeah and now you cannot go here
well okay I guess we still make a drone
but now you actually have to find some
kind of person oh this this pattern
there's a very famous study with this
pattern boards like work against Poland
where you give check and then go back
um I don't know if you know this it's
like pawns on
uh uh the pawns are on G2 and H2 and
then the K9 F6 K9 f8 and really work on
E1 and then you you go all the way one
way all the way the other way yeah
Rook G1 rookie eight draw
okay so King G5 but uh so which one is
can I actually defend this Pawn
probably not right because you might
play H4 now try to take this actually
the funny thing is but this is a very
difficult well actually it's not that
difficult maybe if I trade this Pawn
with all these pawns F and H pawns are a
draw
yeah
although I need to go for this one that
isn't always true though right like it's
it is a draw but it's not it's not
always a draw depending upon where the
pawns are like if the pawns get too far
up the board then then it's usually
winning yeah you need your king to be a
bit more active or you need your king to
be on F7 so it's basically
um
kind of
filter position and the H1 doesn't
matter or sometimes you get like this F
Pawn right you have your King on the
short side Rook on the right alongside
an H Pawn doesn't matter so those are
the defensive resources but there's too
much going on in this position so I
don't think this position is very simple
okay I'm gonna take the pawn it's a free
pawn and white will take this Pawn
yeah and let's try to find a move that
doesn't lose what's the move that we
played here we played King G8 and H4
King G8
no I don't want to play King G8
can we play King G7
you gave me so then came f8 because I
really don't like the fact that my cane
is stuck in the corner and now now I
know if I manage to trade like manage to
take your a pawn I will not lose the
game but obviously this is a this is a
task
yeah if I did this Rook f 3
uh yeah there's this trick so
um Kane E8
and if Rook a a king D7 and if King G7
I'm sorry King G6 King G6 I'll play King
E7
and you know when you like fail
Philadelphia there's like
um so if all of the pawns were off the
board right now except the F Pawn you
would make a draw here by playing King
E7
and then Rook A7 keen f8 and then Kane
F6 it would be king E8 or G8 also makes
a draw and it's the same pattern
yeah this well okay I guess G8 is bad
but so E8 and then if you go to A8 then
King D7 King G6 keaney seven and you
hold the F6 Square and we are close to
having a result in glap toodin versus
kirkazarian oh and this looks like going
to be unstoppable Checkmate
um
a nice nice position for white let's see
how we got here this this is going to be
game over probably has ended already
so Bishop B5 check and annoying move to
face if you're trying to get a combative
game
uh A4 is A4 is interesting so most
people take on D7 instead of playing A4
but yeah Bishop B5 a b is useful for
white so
um there's a guy there's a local master
in St Louis who plays A4 all the time
his name is Roman kozolov I think
somebody was
I see his games
oh yeah there's also a local guy a
little bit less well-known than Roman
kozla Fabiano caruana
who played it against Napoleon she
yeah and this is like actually kind of
annoying to deal with um
uh practically even if objectively like
black is doing pretty well I think that
white keeps a lot of pieces on the board
and you try to outplay your opponent
so G6
and we want a bishop wow big achievement
but okay here this is actually
significant because the C4 Bishop is
extremely annoying
which is why black plays E6 to try to
shut it down
the page for oh this is G5 D5 is always
a committal move uh but in this position
the Knight can land on F4 Queen goes to
F6 so nice squares for the pieces oh he
takes
oh so this is actually very interesting
because now the structure changed the
imbalance right opposite color Bishops
and F4 is weak so I think
it doesn't immediately go after the pawn
because the queen will just land here
and now the Knight is headed to G6 yeah
I actually think I understand why
um y97 is a mistake in the previous
position we would really like to put our
Queen on the F6 Square in 97 blocks like
blocks that path so like Queen D2 Queen
F6 would be very nice and I think the
knight's pretty good on C6 it can even
go to a five later doesn't need to go to
the king site necessarily
so he goes 97 and instead of Queen D2
if you switch his gears and I got a
breaking news the duners actually won
this game while we were analyzing this
so we're expecting
to
an interesting choice by white Switching
gears and going to this side as you
mentioned Knight A5 was a possibility
but now that the Knight has gone to E7
he played
Queen B3 and D5 D5 is a very interesting
choice because you're lacking your own
Bishop in and you're opening this yeah
although I have to say this is a very
difficult decision to make because
you're breaking apart your Pawn
structure
the other hand you get the E5 Square so
I would much prefer to do this than play
the move um I think E5 from black
instead of Ed would be a huge positional
mistake because you you block in your
Bishop
um I and normally in these Keynes Indian
style positions the plan is to go G5 G4
and you don't have a g mod so what are
you gonna do
and without a light Square this attacks
are actually not very good for black
because usually you have plants
associated with H3 right you want to
sacrifice a bishop or when you as you
mentioned G5 G4 like you need the
assistance of this bishop so this is
what I learned long time ago if you're
playing a Kings Indian with black and
you
trade your light Square Bishop then um
it's not very like your attack is not
going to go anywhere okay so Bishop took
actually which makes sense
and this trade happened and now Plex
King looks weaker to me if the Knight
lands on F5 but black does have a very
strong bishop and it takes on A4
and after all this trades happen the
road goes to C6
wait
ah the idea point is you cannot take
only five to six is hanging so even
Queen D7 with a huge thread of Rook G6
otherwise Rook C8 would have been a very
good move
wait but why didn't he take so he just
thought this was better I suppose
because
um I I was thinking the H6 Pawn is Handy
and why not just capture that but
I guess uh yeah Queen D7 is just a
better when you see a good move look for
a better one
absolutely fine well yeah
yeah then gel fans also says when you
see a win play it so I I don't know who
to listen to but you know Queen G4 here
I love Queen D7 because it's too kind of
Tempe right because you're threatening
Rook takes you six winning a queen and
at the same time Queen G4 and
checkmating this King this king is
actually very lonely and this Rook it's
not a really defensive piece
so Queen went to A5 but I think this is
just made by Forest because we win this
Pawn
uh I think Queen F6 was also strongman
and then ah my book is hanging okay so
at some point I have to go to pc1 so
even rookie C1 immediately complete
domination and we have seen this
dominations
um this kind of wins before I wonder if
we're gauge six is it right here if I
pass the move can we do this
I have six is a move so no yeah I think
um and we have analyzed maybe three or
four major PSN games since uh we we keep
saying the same thing which is in major
peace and games the number one factor is
cane safety and in every one of those
games the side with a weaker Kane was on
was on the defend uh on the defense and
not the not the better side yeah
that's a huge threat and this is just
game over this Rook is just dominating
and queen D7 really nice win by clap
congratulations to him uh let's go back
to this Json game let's see what
happened so we have a few moves no not
here so we're left off here Rook G3 King
went to ah Rook G3 we didn't consider
right because we just wanted to say
well what we looked at I think we saw
some version of this so if King went to
H6 and now he takes the pawn and his
point is the King on H6 is worse than
what we were seeing when in this
position when we're taking on H3
and taking the pawn and the king and
some positions could go to F6 and at
least also being closer to the pawn so
Rook G3 King 86 Rook H3 and this might
have been a very clever Nuance by akshot
and I suppose his only move here is Rook
G3 otherwise oh no actually you can play
remember
oh yeah and then the a pawn Waits but no
no now I actually Queen with a check
because another position Euro couldn't
even get a check I was mating you but in
this position
we have
a Quinn
okay so Rook H3 I expect white will take
it King G6
so maybe here
and uh what do we do I wish we didn't I
didn't have all the spawns on the board
so let's say I check
if you take here this is very
comfortable already right yeah I think
I'm quite happy with what has happened
yeah just for K3 and then C4 and we'll
probably trade the C Pawn for the a pawn
and
Mitch just fill the doors
not even a hard version
so this is something he'll be happy with
a we're about
[Music]
Jacob has won his second game in a row
well this position looks absolutely
wild wow I just trying to look at the
materials
and he's about to get another princess a
lot of pieces missing for white and when
we're looking at the opening before the
show started and we're looking at the
position and it looked like black out of
the opening got an extremely comfortable
position
so he just gives up this Pawn we're
saying right and then gets the center
grabs the pawn secures the center
A6 uh you know you're giving your Bishop
a square on A7 so it stays on the
diagonal
Queen steps out of the way I I like this
move 97 because he knows rookie one is
coming and he doesn't want to be at The
Rook ink the same diagonal um it's the
same file as the queen so it plays 97
and sidesteps with a queen right
otherwise maybe white would have tried
some Knight takes D5 tactic followed by
C4 so if you play some some non-move
then
um or something like this yeah Rook do
you want even Castle right yeah take and
see or even euphoria
one of these ideas and White's position
cannot be that bad yeah now all of a
sudden this is looking quite scary right
so he played Queen see someone and I
really like Black's position here next
I'm going to Castle I will put a rook on
G8 you know it's giving me dingler and
napona she wipes a bit right not quite
an E4 and E4 was a mistake in that game
too but now D4 but this position is just
so comfortable because we have the two
Bishops we have the nicer Center more
space P5 is actually a huge threat
trying to trap the Knight next to will
Castle
and Knight G6 to F4 because there's no
Bishop to fight against it so white
plays B3 so the Knight is not trapped
the Knight is headed to G6 but it's not
in a hurito castle but I can actually
Castle may be either away if he chooses
to hold I don't see why he would cancel
the other side I don't think black ever
canceled in this game he left his King
in a center which is a possibility when
the center is locked and there is no way
to break through
so C4 yeah I think that White's
compensation in these sorts of positions
for the bishop with the double G pawns
is the F5 square and there's just no way
to really access that Knight H4 Knight
F5 you would like to do but it's simply
impossible and the other night on A4 is
nowhere near the F5 Square
so I think yeah black just has a very
nice position with no no downside really
so so if you played something like Rook
G8 maybe would play Knight H4 right so
the Knight G6 move possibly can be made
with Knight F5 but at least get some
kind of play although tactically maybe
it doesn't work here oh maybe here we
can at least go Queen H6 and
try to fight against this pawns and try
to put a knight on F5
but Knight G6 just stops this idea it's
very nice C4 and black doesn't react and
now we have a pass Pawn
that goes to F4 Bishop G4 and the attack
is coming already because I simply wanna
take Rook G8 and bring my queen in
so out of desperation excuse me white
decides to give up the exchange and I
think we're going to see how all the
pieces felt so D3
really like this move opening the bishop
so G3 was played Rook G8 I'm taking this
is not possible because of the PIN
so all kinds of trouble for white so
instead Knight went to F5 finally so
then I did get there but at a huge cost
so now Bishop joins the game
another Target in the position well yeah
giving up that cannot feel good but okay
now at least the Knight is joining the
game and now B5 another really nice move
making sure the Knight doesn't land on
D5 creating targeting this weakness on
C4 at least creating a
um removing this guard of the D5 Square
so takes text Rook C1
so I have to say this not as simple as
it looks oh well might be five
so the idea is takes takes
he might have missed Rook d8 backwards
moves are the hardest ones to see but
that is quite a miss
67 but nice
yeah it's just game over so Queen H6 now
is trying to create counter play check
96 backwards moves to backwards most of
the night
okay seven Queen B6 okay the rock is
trapped yeah black is no longer
interested in attacking he's up so much
material that as long as he consolidates
in any sort of way you can give up so
many pieces here and still be winning
like he just hangs his Knight on E6 but
it doesn't matter we have too much
material a really comfortable win by
those background Master his second win
in a raw he had this really beautiful
game again Savion Yesterday When The
Rook from B1 went to B6 F6 faith uh yeah
like a retro puzzle yeah a really nice
win so that's two in a row so
congratulations to him on another
comfortable win and the game we were
looking at in this case in this section
was Tara versus Abu and here it also
looks like we are headed towards uh
drage territory so we started around
here
we started we saw this nitrate
those are The Rook trade
F6 was played E5 and uh it's not even
letting King D6 E5 happened why not that
five
so I think the point is this Pawn
structure can be annoying because now
you cannot really I've just received
news that they've actually drawn their
game so the final position they agreed
to a draw
so that makes sense so Rook goes back
and now this is just three versus two
and then most importantly this bishop
came to life
and the bishop left the game
okay move 40 3 versus 2. not a lot of
tension left in the position Rook D2 is
possible King the two should be possible
um so very reasonable time to end the
game so we still will have a three-way
tie right Darrow Benjamin and
Christopher you yeah the only thing that
could change is Benjamin gladora if he
wins against ilionic could tie for first
I believe ah another opposite the color
Bishop position
but um there's a lot of work to be done
so one two three
example if I take
well yeah yeah that loses
so if I take this way this is also risky
right
it's the one diagonal rule right so I
can set up a fortress like if you play
rookie five here then I can play
oh I was thinking if you go away oh yeah
going away is smart because I don't have
time for D5
if you go away to C4 though is that fine
I'm afraid if I go here you
ready
for two pounds
could I take on D5 though
day five I will take back now Rook end
game with one pawn and gear King is cut
off so if I have time to do this I will
be quite thrilled about this yeah
there's still a lot of danger here
I was I was hoping I could just trade
Rooks without changing the structure but
okay so
oh here you actually can trade Rooks now
here you're gonna win a pawn oh
so maybe this shouldn't wait wait why
can't what wait if I play the move
Bishop G oh no no no no you're yeah
you're right because Bishop G3 you win
my pawn and then when you check me I
attack your Rook oh that also just wins
a piece well okay you can't save the
piece but this
with this no this is not what I'm right
so let's see the position that we have
is after Bishop D5 and is it possible to
play a rook Cafe but Rook Cafe
um I'm quite happy right I also want to
point out that
this is the wrong square and this is
always something you have to think about
this is something that I learned what
Robert has when I was in commentary with
him and when I watched this always
mentioned this when there is a bishop
some kind of Bishop pawn and game always
look at the
uh this corner
and actually once I didn't win a game
against
um
forget
but I was up to Pawns in a bishop and
pawn end game and I allowed this
sacrifice where he gave up his bishop
and then King ran through others where
this um
Square on the like this king would run
to H1 and I couldn't win it I just
completely forgot that it's a defensive
mechanism and there was very sad yeah I
was just up to bonds it's unfortunate I
the thing that always stands out to me
and like this I I just really hate that
the bishop is aligned with with our Rook
on A7 so if we play a move a casual move
like Rook f8 King D3 E4 like black
passes somehow King G7 E4 then C4 well
it would be an unfortunate trick so we
shouldn't fall for this one
it's like my biggest concern I'm like oh
no the bishop on F2 is attacking The
Rook on A7
plot going to Tangles at some point you
will play King F6
and then how do you not how do you move
your pieces oh maybe you can give the F7
I I don't I don't know if we have to
care about that like if we play cane F6
and then like white doesn't do anything
and we play King E5 and just give the F7
Pawn I think I'm happy to play this end
game as long as I can play the move D5
where do you want to go oh I was
thinking potentially actually I could
play keany five here because if you play
Rook F7 Rook F7 D5 might might actually
be an attempt
although here maybe you play E4
no no I don't like to have to have
separated
I'm thinking you just want to give up
this one but real Cafe is very passive
right so let's say here King G7
um
Maybe
what can I do
so can I
I want to get in like G5 H4 with my king
on G4 and I feel like you cannot move
but immediately I can't of course
because G5 Bishop H4 yeah and this it's
always the danger of putting pawns on
the same color as your opponent's
opposite colored Bishop
they might hang Wonder
this is silly oh
yeah Rook D7 and if it's only one Pawn
then
might not be so dangerous yeah one Pond
and still activity so if I went upon on
trade Rooks I'll be quite happy
okay a lot of work to be done
and the last game we haven't looked at
is some Savion versus yesterday
has lost two games in a row I believe so
nothing's up in extreme
exchange and what is going on let's
count bonds one two three four five six
one two three four five okay is up upon
and a
exchange is it so easy though this night
is quite annoying
so what to do it's not easy to move this
nuts if I was hanging it doesn't look so
simple I would like to play Queen D3 but
my knight hangs
um
this one can you defend this one
always play Bishop F1
and the King two one on E3
I I want to be able to play Knight C3 at
some point
I I don't want to hang this Pawn with a
check I just um
the pawn
at some point I need to play Knight C3
and but Knight C3 hangs okay if I pass a
move
so if I pass a move yeah and you take I
just want to see if how dangerous this
is I think this is scary right thinking
maybe you could even take on C5 with
your knight I wasn't sure how you were
going to react to that oh I was so
afraid of pictures
about this
but
um it's my only move right I'm actually
I couldn't it's kind of funny here
because here this has to be very bad
and B4 is coming before it's coming
well okay here you're paralyzed right
because you cannot take my Pawn almost
yeah I missed that my queen had very
little squares I mean I completely
missed 95 but okay three it was a nice
resource which means after Knight C3
Rook A3 is a huge threat
in that line we're looking at so Bishop
f8 I'm just passing
Knight C3
so what I was trying to figure out how
scary is this for black and I think this
looks quite scary because I want to
check and take and if you take this
looks without this Knight my Rook all of
a sudden looks very scary right
yeah I I don't I don't like this
position at all for black so if you
don't trust now my rule comes in
so we were talking about major peace and
games you're uh your campaign week well
one side has major pieces in the other
the other side doesn't have as many
major pieces
so if we do
with the end game so rookie 3 was played
so Rook F7 we're gonna see those lines
we're analyzing something very similar
because this look actually very forced
white has a very strong thread
age and uh I'll be the true Benjamin bar
Christopher YouTube long time ago so the
two games we have going are some Serbian
versus
Benjamin gladora
immediately ah so you just wait so if I
take oh he just doesn't care because
Bishop G2 the way I said because it's
like I was about to say something very
smart but I'm still unsure okay so
rookie three huge threat so I'm going to
take
we're actually going to get an interview
with duden which is 23 it's very cool
[Music]
okay so 93 immediately it's not a movie
we're considering
and I would uh so Bishop C5 is also a
possibility here but
is it possible Queen E5 is are these
lines oh this is not possible now this
is defended
and um but now this looks actually
somehow more dangerous because F5 is
possibly hanging in some lines
is Queen B8 Queen B7 idea is there and
taking this now E2 is defended and
it is defendant and now this rooku is
going to come in and again F5 is hanging
here Queen E6 is a huge threat attacking
this bishop so this Knight C3 move was a
great move by some Serbian immediately
trying to dislodge this knight from C5
and also Rook A3 is a threat so if it
were
way to move white could also play Rook
Gate 3 and ask this queen where it's
going and the queen actually doesn't
have too many options the only Square we
found in the other line was C4 so the
queen is very uncomfortable and we do
have a guest with us we have Colette who
just won his game against kirkasayan
congratulations on your win uh let's
let's take a look at your game so take
us through your game please uh yeah so
uh let's start from the first move uh
basically
I never play E4 but these days
I mean it's hard to uh it's hard to play
against these guys who who just prepare
against everything so
I had to surprise
and yeah just
if it was a good way so C5 mainly I
prepare for E5 but okay uh C4 C5 Knight
F3
here expected Knight C6
okay anyway I was just going to play
something probably should be fine yeah
we should be fine as you can predict but
uh yeah didn't know much they were here
so D6
okay here basically I started to to to
to think on my own
I knew some lines played it a few times
but okay Bishop B5 just wanted to get
some like new game
uh get out of the bidden track Bishop D7
A4
yeah okay so basically here we started
just to play on uh with our own head and
okay A6 so you think he also didn't know
the slides because he went C5 it was
unexpected yeah
I guess he he didn't expect A4
he didn't like
he plays a lot of things but uh yeah
just A4 must be a rare move
so this is what the whole idea of my
opening just to play something new
bishop C4 Knight C6
it looks like a English opening for
black something similar Knight F6 rookie
one Bishop G4
yeah here D3 there was a moment he could
have played uh Bishop F3
queen of 395. Queen G3 Knight C4 DC so
what do you think about the structure
yeah this should be pretty good for
guides so I'm just gonna go Knight C4
Bishop G5 then Rook D1 E5 oh so what
what is okay so black has to play with
E6 now but after A6 we have witness on
D6 so
it's nicely free Bishop before or maybe
later yeah yeah okay one so your moves
are just easy yeah I just have a easy
game and
three one two six uh yeah Bishop G7 and
you got this bishop yeah
and use some lines from rosalima uh with
D6 there are similar positions
but white as Bishop on F1 I have some
small Edge
so
it's uh
it's exactly what I like to play
yeah here okay
probably he wants to play D5 at some
point
and so you're stopping yeah just what
white rooms are so natural so that I
don't even have to commentate them
so how did you feel about this G5 yeah
from uh this moments like after each two
to to to move uh two moves of him I was
just uh
he was surprising me on uh
on on each move so you weren't expecting
G5 I was but I thought it's it cannot be
great for for black
because here I still have this light
Square bishop and
he doesn't really have any any push on
the king side so I just uh I just use
this King weakness weaknesses on at some
point and D5 here yeah
right okay this positions are yeah maybe
you should you should take with the
Knight but yeah still I just play Bishop
A2 and oops or Bishop B3 it doesn't
matter probably yeah it's just weakness
is even worse yeah he is nothing not
nothing to nothing where to push and I
just 95 somewhere it's it's very easy
so he runs my H5 so you saved your
Bishop on Knight F4 were you surprised
by another 14. uh
he has to yes to continue his line so I
think 94 is logical at this point
here I go D4 and yeah I thought it just
should be better
uh the arrow CH Rook C1 Heroes
calculating D5 instead of uh okay yeah
D5 also here is possible but Eddie just
Bishop B3 it's
it's visible that black is
just like busted D5 F4 King Witnesses oh
here you wanted to go D5 uh yeah but
it's a bit premature because I I can I I
don't have to rush in Knight E5 Bishop
A2 but I don't have to to do this at all
so you just centralized your rook and 97
and 97 is actually a mistake by hand
yeah something computer thinks is a
mistake and with that it's a mistake
because
um maybe this queen F6 move is not
available but you switch gears and then
now you're going after this Pawn
I think he wanted to play like
positionally wanted to put Knight on G6
and then just try to wait
so uh yeah play Queen V3
uh Community seven but I wasn't really
thinking of D5 at first
uh
uh because I thought I should I should
go for F4 pawn something like Queen
before
so that is I want to play Queen Queen D2
but then he has Knight G6 so first
uh oh just imagine uh I want to go H4
and then I'm turning Queen D2 because
after Knight G6 I have H5 okay I'll just
pass them all
right yeah something like this
so 96 can be met by each yeah and we win
upon
and this is actually difficult to deal
with because it's not like he wants to
ever put H5 because he will just come
and take the pawn eventually
so why did you change your mind and
decide to go for D5 yeah so mainly after
D5 I was looking uh on E5
I thought that Knight H4 is not playable
here because of Bishop F6 and I'm not in
time to play Bishop E2 and Bishop G4
but instead I can just go Knight D2 and
F5
Bishop D3
the Knight C4 and if he tries to yeah I
just have I'm completely controlling
light squares and
yeah yes and if he takes you take it
yeah 95 takes yeah 25 F3
what's the complete domination probably
has yeah but then it's still very bad I
just go 94 and he has no chances to to
attack
yeah but talk about
Bishop the long uh Prospect of a bishop
and sometimes at the Knight just
dominates it just seems such a recurring
theme so he decided to go D5 and he
takes and how did you feel about this
trade because this looks very exposed
now that the yeah I actually was a bit
pessimistic about my position so I was
thinking that uh I have some slight Edge
because of the
King Witnesses
but uh it shouldn't be too bad for black
why what is Black's counter play uh well
basically uh my my main idea is to go
Knight h495 somewhere
and as we can see later uh
the main idea is to try to exchange as
many points as possible
yeah and uh of course why can't it can
it uh exchange the Queens
so uh someone we should
uh
yeah we can see later what happened so
he took took Rook B8 Queen D5 uh Bishop
B2 so here I thought that uh he has to
give up D6 and F4 Pawns
and just for example Bishop G7 mm-hmm so
I don't know Rook D6
and something like Queen B5 Queen D2 A5
oh just play for counter yeah before A4
E5 and that just bet everything on a
pawn and maybe he will survive maybe not
but if he doesn't get made it will
survive yeah but uh I'm also playing
with fire here because a pawn is rolling
and either I I like I made him more or
it's oh he gets a queen yeah
like this movie played Queen D7 yeah
basically Bishop E5 I just I was just
sitting for three minutes with the like
with the same face
and I didn't know what to what to like
how to react because it's just yeah
one zero yeah immediately yeah King is
absolutely exposed yeah Queen E7 is a
nice move to finish but anyway it's
yeah it's a hurricane
sorry to go here and then we saw this
you come completely dominating on the C
file and once the rule comes in this is
just
complete domination yeah really nice win
and it's a really nice finish to the
game congratulations on your win who who
do you play in the next two rounds you
know um playing Contour with black
country yes black and then you finish
with uh Akshay Chandra Chandra okay well
good luck to you in the next games and
hopefully we'll see you again after some
victories and I was clapped out in after
his victory against Kurt Kazarian and
let's take a look at the standings as we
do have a lot of results coming in so as
of right now in group a we have a big
tie the same tie we had when we started
the game between Daria sweets
Christopher you and Benjamin Bach with
four points and yeah good boy who won
his game in a really convincing fashion
half a point behind
and if Benjamin gladora and Ilya niznik
draw their game they will join yakuboy
for a tie for fourth place
and in the big group we also have quite
a few results and so far actually the
game we're looking at for Jason Liang
versus Akshay Chandra that game ended in
a trial which puts Jason in a tie for
first place but Felix he's not going to
lose his game so he will either be
leading with five and a half points or
at least five points and it looks like
he's going to take a very big lead so
actually let's take a quick look at that
game and see if he has made any progress
where we left off uh it was around move
I believe
somewhere around here right
so Quincy it was played we're thinking
actually Queen E8 and eventually he took
on G7 so what would that would happen
happened
and so now the position transposed to
Queen versus two Rooks and queen uh the
side with the queen also has two Pawns
and this must be a huge Advantage for
white of course because the pawn is just
rolling
I wonder if A5 was possible
but maybe he's afraid of some checks so
he just plays a prophylactic move King
A2
rule goes to C5 so King D7 trying to go
closer to the Pawns
can get three
so now white is starting to get ready to
push the pawn but I still think it's a
bit tricky with the Rooks
King goes back
so check again so now
um this must be a treatment to push the
king away
and
King before defending all the pawns so
at some point white will play B3 because
the spawns are hanging
and uh what is so let's say if I put a
rook on A1 you play B3 and I go King D7
what is the way for white to win maybe
A5 immediately is winning
and something and by immediately winning
I mean this end game
so actually the lane Chandra game was
prematurely called so there haven't been
any any results at the top but
nevertheless it's very likely that Felix
is going to uh be at least a full point
ahead or sorry at least the Half Point
ahead of everyone else if if not just a
not just a full point
so do we take a look at the other game
quickly before we sign off because
that's also very relevant for our
standing so where we left off was here
so check was played one was taken
so I think we're analyzing this I don't
think we sell all of this so Rook G3 and
King goes to F6 so my table base tells
me that every move is okay for black
I would expect
um what would I expect probably a pump
push
oh we were looking at this right but
we're looking at this with the pawn on
H2 which actually starting to forget how
that happened right
but probably it's very similar I don't
think you can stop the pawn from getting
to H2 and
I mean we prematurely call this a draw
but uh maybe it's going to be a draw
anyway
still going so we're we're thinking but
every time we call something it doesn't
happen so it's most likely this game in
a draw and would think that Felix will
be able to convert his Advantage which
will keep him still in clear first place
right and in the a group none of the
leaders have really changed so um
uh with that uh uh please join us
tomorrow for uh vars lecture on uh Bobby
uh Bobby Bobby Fisher's um beautiful
games uh played against Boris basky uh
mihail tall and of course some games in
the uh famous Ben Larson and Ty monof
match uh time on of matches where of
course Fisher went uh six and zero so
please join us tomorrow on the World
Chess Hall of fame's YouTube channel
okomion is going to be analyzing some uh
Fisher games
and thank you everyone for joining us
today we will be back here tomorrow at
the usual time so please join us for the
round eight of the spring chess classic
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited